I have experienced this myself
because like many countries of the south
or like,
for example,
the American Rand Corporation
for a negotiated solution in Ukraine advertising
I have also been told by many colleagues
who are present here today
repeatedly described as putina or pro Russian
and in this context I would also really like to make 1 appeal to them
it is their legitimate right
not to like us
and prefer other parties or not share our positions
but please deal with the factually
what we represent and do not go the cheap way
to insinuate things to us
that we do not represent at all
or to sit or bring ourselves close to shady people
with whom we have nothing to do
I say this from current occasion
so next to the alleged Putin Nail that is always accused of us
was featured in a high-reach newspaper last week
i would strive for a state economy of all the gDR and i can only say that
reading thus forms
I have now really in my books
my ideas about it presented in relatively detail
like My goal of a fair Leistungsgesellschaft
looks like more competition and a strong middle class
and our common wirtschaftspolitischen ideas
can be found in the presented founding manifesto
what was also distributed here
so please stand with our positions as we represent them
apart
and suppress the temptation to misrepresent and also to campaign
I do not say that because I am afraid of it
so I think the younger time has enough examples
holds enough examples ready
that campaigns
have strengthened rather than weakened the addressee
but I say that
because I find
we should in the interest of
of a reasonable climate of opinion and in the interest of democracy
be fair with each other thank you very much